is it possible for our prayers to change
the course of someone's life let's
unravel the truth today but let's pray
first Father in Heaven as we study
intercessory prayer this uh so important
topic teach us the truth of your word
and teach us the power of intercessory
prayer we pray in Jesus name
amen the Apostle Paul was an old man now
there were deeply etched lines in his
face his hands were trembling his gray
hair Bei his age and he
recognized that he had to say something
significant something important to the
churches that he had planted in the
Mediterranean Basin so as the result of
that in prison in
Rome pain racking his body he's been
Shipwrecked in
stoned beaten with
rods here the Apostle Paul writes to the
church at Philippi and in Philippians
chapter 1 Paul says I thank my God upon
every remembrance of you always in every
prayer of mine making request for you
all with joy the Apostle Paul says I'm
in prison in Rome and I'm writing back
to the church at Philippi and I'm
praying for you
intercessory prayer is
biblical but then Paul invites the
church to pray for him they were not
together they were hundreds of miles
apart and Paul in Philippians 1 vers 19
says this for I know that this what's he
talking about I know this I know this
trial this difficulty I know this
imprisonment that I'm going through I
know this will turn out for my salvation
through your prayer and the supply of
the spirit of Christ what does Paul mean
this will turn out for my salvation
wasn't Paul saved on Damascus Road he
was how could their prayers in
Philippi impact Paul in Rome he says so
turn it to my salvation another word for
salvation the word there is suia in the
Greek original language and it means
healing so what Paul is saying there is
I'm going through a trial I'm going
through difficulty
and because you are praying for me the
difficulty is not going to destroy me
but it's going to heal my soul in ways
that it draws me closer to Christ
because through your prayer I will be
drawn closer to Jesus intercessory
prayer is biblical now what is
intercessory prayer intercessory prayer
is prayers in which we pray for another
person all through the New Testament you
find that for for example let's go to
the book of Ephesians chapter 1 and we
find again in Ephesians 1 verse 15 and
16 therefore Paul says I also after I
heard of your faith in the Lord Jesus
and your love for all the saints do not
cease to give thanks for you for making
mention of you in my prayers Paul says
church at at Ephesians we're not with
you but I'm praying for you and I know
it's going to make a difference well
what was Paul praying specifically about
that the god of our Lord Jesus Christ
the father of Glory may give to you the
spirit of wisdom and Revelation in the
knowledge of him that the eyes of your
understanding being enlightened that you
may know what is the hope of your
calling what are the riches of the glory
of his inheritance of the Saints he's
writing at the church at Ephesus what
was Ephesus like Ephesus was a city of
maybe 150,000 up to 180,000 people it
was a Seaport City It was a commercial
center
goods from all over the world were
shipped into that City it was the fourth
largest city in the Roman Empire you
have Rome Alexandria Antioch and Ephesus
it was probably the richest wealthiest
city in the Empire at least one of the
top two or three it was a Godless
materialistic secular sex centered
thrill jaded morally Twisted society and
there in the middle of that Society Paul
had raised up the church in Ephesus and
he writes back to them and he was saying
never forget the hope of your calling
I'm praying that you'll never lose sight
of your identity uh I'm praying that
you'll sense that your sons and
daughters of God Paul believed in
intercessory prayer but you say wait a
minute isn't God doing everything he can
for my son my daughter my husband my
wife whether I pray pray or not here's I
have a son maybe that doesn't know
Christ isn't God doing everything he can
for them isn't he sending his holy
spirit to their heart isn't he
enlightening their mind isn't he working
in their behalf he is but in the
controversy between good and evil there
are ground rules and one of those ground
rules is God will never violate the
freedom of choice of another because if
he would do that Satan would cry unfair
God is a dictator and vindictive judge
and a wrathful tyrant and he manipulates
people's Wills God
Longs for us to come to him based on who
he is his loving
character but when we pray for somebody
else God can look at Satan and say just
as I respect the individual who's being
prayed for just as I respect their
freedom of will freedom of conscience
their choice I respect Mark Finley's
choice in praying for them and the River
of Water of Life is poured out from
Heaven through the intercessor to touch
that person's life you say is that
biblical it is our intercessory prayers
enable God to do more because we're
praying than he couldn't do if we didn't
pray first John chapter 5 there are many
passages in the Bible that talk about
intercessory prayer and its importance
and power there are just a few that tell
you what happens when we pray there are
just a few that pull the curtain aside
one of them is 1 John chapter 5 and
notice verse 16 if anyone sees his
brother sinning a sin which does not
lead to death what's the sin that
doesn't lead to death or what is the sin
that leads to death the sin that leads
to death is the unpardonable sin now the
only sin that God will not pardon is the
sin that we do not confess we cling to
and re openly knowingly rebel against
him and pretty soon our our hearts
become hardened and we don't hear the
voice of the holy spirit anymore so if
anyone sees his brother sending a sin
that does not lead to death he doesn't
commit the unpardonable sin he who's
that he the intercessor will ask what
does it mean he'll ask it means he'll
intercede for that person he'll pray for
that person and he who's that he Capital
H that he that's God will give him who
is the him the intercessor Life For
Those who commit sin that doesn't lead
to death what an amazing reality when we
pray as
intercessors God gives us life for those
that sin not unto death does it mean
they are saved because of us no it means
that the life of God flows through us to
touch their life not to force or coerce
their will but to beat back the angels
of Hell to convince and convict them of
Truth so they're more likely to accept
it so they have a better opportunity a
better choice our prayers do not
manipulate another person's will but
they open vistas of understanding they
open channels of light Ellen White in
the book second selected messages page
377 makes this amazing statement it's
such a powerful statement that I wrote
it in my Bible ministering angels are
waiting about The Throne of God where
are the ministry Angels waiting around
the Throne of God to do what to
instantly obey the mandate of Jesus
Christ in answer to every prayer offered
in Living Faith so here you have a son
or daughter that doesn't know Christ you
brought them up to be faithful to Jesus
one night they're about ready to go into
some Pub or nightclub you don't know
where they are they're in some major
city and you're on your knees praying oh
God be with my daughter Alice be with my
son John Lord they were brought up in a
Godly home Lord they don't know you your
prayers Ascend to Heaven ministering
angels are standing about the throne
waiting for the Mandate of Christ to
answer prayer your prayers Ascend to the
most holy place where Jesus is and Jesus
looks at the angel and he says you go
you go and the angel descends from
Heaven and the angel Works to beat back
the forces of hell not to manipulate
your son or daughter's choice but to
enable a new light to go into their mind
and that person remembers their child
and they say I'm not going to go there
now our all of our prayers answered when
we pray for our children our neighbors
yes they are not one is not because the
Bible says this in 1 John 5 verse4 this
is the confidence that we have in him
that if we ask anything according to his
will he hears us is it God's will to
save your son or your daughter it is
where is the confidence in our prayers
no we kneel and in faith of confidence
in
Christ every prayer is
answered as we pray Angels descend as we
pray the Holy Spirit works in the heart
of another does that mean they always
will respond
no it doesn't mean they will always
respond but it does mean that if they
don't
respond they're troubled inside they're
convicted inside I've had people so
troubled that uh they when we were
praying for them that these the
troubling LED them to just totally
abandon their previous activity there
was a wife who came to an Evangelistic
meeting of a pastor I wasn't holding
this particular meeting and uh she
invited her husband to come he said I'm
not coming I have no interest in
religion I'm going hunting and fishing
this weekend when the Evangelist was
having the meetings his wife came to the
pastor and told the pastor that the
pastor organized a prayer group with the
wife they began to pray and pray and
pray last night of the meetings this man
came the wife didn't know it she was
sitting about the third row he came in
late sat right at the end and the right
at the last Pew of the church the
Evangelist made an appeal and this man
get up came forward under such
conviction his wife talked to him later
and he said look I had no intention of
coming but I couldn't sleep all night
something was convicting me I had to
come to this meeting and I gave my heart
to Jesus when we pray great controversy
page
525 by Ellen White God will do in answer
to the prayer of faith that which he
would not do did we not thus ask in
intercessory prayer makes a difference
taking one person at a time praying for
that person job 16 verse 21 notice the
specificity of this passage Job
16 verse
21 oh that one oh that what everybody
one might plead with a man for a man
with God oh that one might plead for a
man with God that is the work of
intercession writing the name of a son a
daughter a husband or wife that doesn't
know Christ my father prayed for my
mother for over 10 years and eventually
the spirit of God convicted her through
some providential circumstances in her
life to accept Jesus fully to accept the
bible message to become part of the
Adventist Community oh that one might
plead for a man with God
as a man pleads for his neighbor this
work of praying for people by name did
you know that Jesus prayed for people by
name he did we're looking here at the
Book of Luke if you have your Bible
you're taking notes you're looking at
Luke chapter
22 verse
31 and the Lord said Simon Simon Satan
has asked for you you that he might sift
you as wheat did Satan know the
potential of Peter did Satan know that
Peter had the potential to become a
mighty warrior for God a great preacher
for God a leader in the New Testament
Church he knew all that didn't he he he
could see Peter's potential sat so Jesus
says Simon Simon Satan has asked for you
who do you think Satan asked think he
asked God I'd like Peter and you think
God would say okay no not at all you
think yet no I think Satan went to his
evil angels and said look that man has
tremendous potential I want him that's
why Satan wants to destroy our youth
because he knows the potential they have
Jesus says Simon Simon indeed Satan has
asked for you that he may sift you as
weep but I've prayed for you and when
you
have returned to me strengthen your
brethren I prayed for you that your
faith would not fail Jesus prayed for
Peter by name as we pray for people by
name God where Works powerfully in their
lives do you have a prayer list are you
praying by name for those that don't
know Christ but there's something else I
want to share about this just as Jesus
prayed for Peter by name Jesus is
praying for you by
name you are on his lips today you are
in his heart today he is our great high
priest in the sanctuary above and you
remember
the high priest had the names of the
tribes of Israel inscribed on each of
his shoulders why because he was strong
enough to carry them you remember the
names of the children of Israel were
inscribed on the heart of the high
priest why because he understood their
needs their heartaches and their sorrows
and his heart went out to them and the
high priest's role was to pray for
Israel it's one of his roles Jesus
has you on his lips today you are in his
heart today he is strong enough to carry
your burdens today when the journey is
long when the mountain is high when the
road is rough when the valley is dark
never give up because Jesus is praying
for you at this point you understand the
power of praying for others but could
there be things in our own lives that
hinder our prayers if you want to know
the answer watch this video
next